often we hear that actually Kingston is
a strategic genius for picking a fight
with the left of his party which you've
seen over Jeremy corbyn and I think that
has helped kisama to show he is
different but I think here it's not just
the left of the party that's pretty
appalled that this cat could say it's
also empties across the party and I
think it's a Jammer rule if MPS across
the party in the different tribes uh all
very unhappy and making that known this
week quite a fiery weekly meeting of the
Parliamentary party that's a bad place
for a leader to be because it raises
questions about whether he can really
Hold the Line depending on what size
majority received if he was in
government and it all comes back to
fiscal responsibility ultimately Rachel
Reeves and kirstana think that it is
more important to show they're not going
to spend in a way which the Tories can
attack as making the economy worse but I
think here this has not been a clear
message and actually is causing because
Donald quite a lot of problems
um in terms of his own party